A recent CNBC interview with a billionaire
has gone viral.
The billionaire effectively said, who cares
if some billionaires lose money because of
Corona virus?
There is an interesting billionaire, a guy
I've been following for a while.
His name is Chumash Polish Pedia and he's
believed to be just barely a billionaire.
What I mean by that is he was worth about
1.1 billion before the Corona virus fiasco.
Maybe he's not a billionaire today.
Who knows?
He's roughly a billionaire.
And what's interesting about math is
that he's a venture capitalist.
He was an early Facebook executive, but he
seems to have more of an understanding, maybe
because he grew up in a family that depended
on welfare benefits.
He seems to better understand that an economy
really is about the majority, not about the
billionaires.
And I've been seeing more and more interesting
interviews with timothe on CNBC and elsewhere.
He recently did a great interview with Anthony
Pompe Liano, one of our friends who has a
YouTube channel that you can check out.
But a few days ago he was interviewed by CNBC
Scott Wapner about the economy in the context
of the Corona virus.
And Scott Wapner started to wax poetic about,
oh, what if billionaires lose money?
And Shamash said, quite simply, who cares?
And the who cares was so simple that it visibly
confused Scott Wapner.
So I'll set it up
for you.
This all started because timothe Palio Pedia
started to explain what we should not do.
As we look at bailing out companies during
Corona virus and what he said we shouldn't
do is we shouldn't prop up zombie companies
merely to save the employees that you often
hear.
We've got to bail this company out because
the employees think of the employees and Shamos
explains why this is a false notion.
Check it out.
But are you suggesting you keep saying propping
up zombie companies?
Are you?
Are you arguing to let airlines, for example,
fail?
Why?
I mean, how does that make sense in the broader
scheme of the economy, because it's not because
when you look at what it means, this is why
I'm saying like this is a lie that's been
supported by Wall Street.
When a company fails, it does not fire their
employees.
It goes through a packaged bankruptcy.
Right.
If anything, what happens is the people who
have the pensions inside those companies,
the employees of these companies, end up owning
more of the company.
The people that get wiped out are the speculators
that own the unsecured tranches of debt for
the folks that own the equity.
And by the way, those are the rules of the
game.
That's right.
Because these are the people that fought to
be the most sophisticated investors in the
world.
They deserved to get wiped out, but the employees
don't get wiped out.
So this is a really important point just to
start with.
Very often the justification for bailing out
a company is you've got to save the employees.
Now, there are good and bad reasons to bail
out a company.
But timothe points out for these huge companies
like airlines.
They don't just go bankrupt, lay ever everybody
off, say buy, buy, sell their airplanes for
peanuts and you never hear from them again.
Bankruptcy for these huge companies is a process
that includes restructuring.
It often includes golden parachutes or big
payouts for the executives, but it includes
all sorts of mechanisms for reorganizing.
And very often not always, these bankruptcies
work out OK for the employees.
Not all of them in every case, but in many
cases.
And tomorrow is explaining that.
So now Scott Wapner starts to wonder where
timothe is going with this.
And it gets even
better.
Take a look.
Why does anybody understand?
Why does anybody deserve using your word to
get wiped out from a crisis created like like
this?
How does anybody deserve to get wiped out?
Well, but just be clear.
Like, who are we talking about?
We're talking about a hedge fund that serves
a bunch of billionaire family officers.
Who cares?
Let them get wiped out.
They don't get to summer in the Hamptons.
Who cares?
I mean, there you go.
You don't look down, you got you don't think
the employees of these companies own stocks.
I mean, own their stocks.
Own the company stocks.
You can you can look on Bloomberg and you
can see what percentage of these companies
are typically owned by thieves.
These things are owned by BlackRock.
These things are owned by these huge, you
know, a Morpheus organization.
Ultimately downstream and the employee owns
a few hundred dollars or a few thousand thousand
dollars of Schweitzer's dollars.
This is a key moment.
The employees don't deserve to get wiped out.
They're not engaging in speculative activity
of little benefit to the economy.
They're just working their jobs.
The billionaires and the hedge funds and the
speculators.
They also don't deserve to get wiped out.
But this is risk reward.
The billionaires and the hedge funds and the
speculators, they are choosing to take a risk
for a possibly huge reward.
You can't just bail them out of that risk.
This is the risk they decided to take on the
risk and reward need to be in concert.
They are risking getting wiped out to possibly
get the huge reward of making crazy money.
They then get to another ruse, which is this
idea of hey.
But the employees are shareholders.
If the share price collapse, that hurts the
employees.
I've said this before.
The stock market is
not an indicator of the health of the economy.
It is true.
Many companies have employee stock purchase
programs.
Employees own stock in their company to some
degree.
But as timothe points out, it is disproportionately
tiny amounts of stock.
The stock is mostly held by executives, by
investment firms like BlackRock and others
outside of the company.
It is another ruse that is used to justify
bailing out every company without actually
thinking critically about whether they should
be bailed out.
Let's now check out just the last portion.
That it sound like a natural disaster.
And why does anybody deserve to get wiped
out?
Wouldn't that be immoral in and of itself?
No, because what's happening right now is
what I'll tell you is on Main Street today,
people are getting wiped out.
And right now, rich CEOs are not board.
They've had horrible governance or not.
Hedge funds are not.
People are six million people.
Just this week alone, basically thing.
Holy mackerel.
I don't know how I'm going to make, you know,
my own expenses for the next few weeks, days,
months.
So it's happening today to individual American
and what we've done is disproportionately
prop up and protect, you know, poor performing
CEOs, companies and boards.
And you have to wash these people out.
Let me introduce an idea here.
It's sort of a combination of an evolutionary
idea and an economic idea.
The Corona virus is terrible.
It's a pandemic.
It's a crisis.
There's endless suffering, death and destruction
as a result.
In a way, it can also serve as a sort of filter.
For example, there is the idea that our behavior
on earth is so damaging to the planet.
And then you look at the pandemic, air travels
down 95 percent.
Global carbon emissions are down, areas clearing,
water is clearing, pollution is declining.
It's going above and beyond our normal actions.
And something is saying, nope, we're going
to reverse the trend briefly and work as a
sort of filter when it comes to economics.
There is a ton of nonproductive speculative
vulture activity that is not economically
productive.
We talk about an economic multiplier.
That's the factor by which
one type of economic activity multiplies through
the economy.
So you build a factory or you finance some
mortgages.
These actions have different multipliers.
A ton of the stuff that's being propped up
with these bailouts is very low multiplier
action, speculation, derivative trading, leverage
stuff.
It generates profit for the people doing it,
but it is a very little economic value.
Maybe this crisis is an opportunity to filter
out some of that nonsense that helps hedge
funds make a ton of money, but is not particularly
good for the economy.
Really interesting stuff.
Check out other interviews with Kumar.
Call your Pedia that he's done recently.
Very interesting.
Billionaire.
We'll take a quick break and we have so much
more coming up.